foreign
[Music]
super excited to have you guys here to
tell you a little bit more about what's
happening in Google Maps platform hope
you had a good keynote down below or
wandering through the sessions we also
have some demos down below so hopefully
you get a chance to see that
um so I'm Celine van Gran I'm a product
manager on the Google Maps platform in
the Geo sustainability team I'm joined
by a few of my colleagues here I've been
with Google for nine years I've been
building impact focused action-oriented
sustainability products for those years
and this is the culmination of some of
our products that we're gonna going to
show you today so I'll tell you a little
bit about the environmental category
then we will spend a little bit of time
on the apis themselves and we'll have a
little bit of time for questions
so let me start with Google
sustainability Google's been focused on
sustainability for a long time
especially in our operations being the
first company in 2007 to become fully
carbon neutral to creating you know
buying the largest corporate renewable
energy purchase in 2019 to our current
24 7 carbon free goals which are Super
ambitious
this work not only leads the industry
but it really helps Drive larger systems
change and when you know you think of
Google's expertise and our mission it's
really about making information
accessible and useful for better
decision making and So within
sustainability at Google we really think
of it as three pillars of course on our
operations as I mentioned but there's
also how do we Empower individuals how
do we Empower our partners which is why
a lot of you might be here today so
addressing climate change
is really an information problem in many
ways in fact in a report that we
commissioned in 2022 we found that 20 to
25 percent of all of the initiatives
that the EU needs to do to reach their
deep decarbonization goals have some
form of digital enablement there
and for individuals and our partners
really to drive that positive action for
our planet
it really means you know we need to
access the billions of users that use
our products every day with things like
eco-friendly routing air quality
monitoring or putting the carbon number
next to Google Flights and then the
flights that people are purchasing it
also means building new tools and
platforms so in 2010 we launched Google
Earth engine a geospatial analysis
platform really to look at environmental
monitoring in 2018 we launched the
environmental insights Explorer tool
focused on bringing actionable data and
insights for thousands of cities around
the world
but what's really important here is that
right now
consumers are interested in
sustainability more than ever before in
2022 searches for
electric vehicles electric bicycles
solar energy reached all-time highs and
people around the world are really
interested in you know what how do I
live more sustainably what's going on
here and that's spurred on by of course
extreme weather events local pollution
new incentive programs it's also by the
kind of critical mass of friends and
families and neighbors who have either
had some impact associated with climate
change or maybe have seen the benefits
of sustainable behaviors and
Technologies and so now really more than
ever before this is the time when it
makes sense for businesses to offer
solutions to Consumers that can help
inform and enable those sustainable
choices
enter Google Maps platform Google Maps
platform is really about providing the
information to developers based on the
most up-to-date
accurate and constantly evolving
understanding of the real world it's GMP
enables organizations to create amazing
geospatial experiences you've probably
seen Google Maps in a lot of different
places for their users based on the
trusted information that we've been
building within Google Maps for decades
and so when you combine these two one
Google's long-standing commitment to
sustainability and GMP Google Maps
platform is a developer platform that's
why we're super excited to launch the
environment category in GMP this is
really our first step towards making GMP
Google Maps platform we'll keep using
that acronym the leading destination for
developers to access unique hyper local
sustainability and climate data and
insights
and today that's where we are launching
three new apis solar API air quality and
pollen that you'll hear a little bit
more about today
these products apply Ai and machine
learning to environment data to give
businesses helpful information that can
inform consumers daily behaviors that
can help inform purchasing decisions and
can make businesses operate more
uh more efficiently right reduce the
time and cost of doing business
and GMP of course offers the reliability
and scale for develop for supporting
developers around the world it offers
really an ideal platform for us to bring
to partner with developers and bring
that information to bear that will
ultimately help us address climate
change
so let me dive a little bit deeper into
solar itself that's the product I've
been working on for a number of years
the opportunity of course I have to say
this for solar is brighter than ever
really residential and commercial solar
in the last year makes up 50 percent of
all the expected growth in solar in 2023
and in 2024 the International Energy
agency predicts that 100 over 150
gigawatts of solar energy will be
installed that is tens of millions of
systems around the world
and that's really fueled by policy
makers who are setting this great policy
environment through incentive programs
especially here in the US and Europe and
and you know it helps get you know
solars easy to install it happens really
quick and it reduces the energy cost
burden for individual building owners
so what is you know what is this API
itself what we did is we took high
quality imagery and Maps data we use AI
models to analyze that imagery to
understand the details about the
individual roofs including the slope
obstructions shade patterns and then we
add in weather to understand what is the
solar potential what how much solar
energy will be produced by those
rooftops
and so we can we in the API we return it
in two different formats one is the raw
data the raw data is an imagery layer so
you can see the actual house that you're
going to be putting solar on it we give
you a DSM a digital surface model which
is an elevation a pitch and shape of the
roof itself as well as flux so sunniness
and shade values across the entire year
for that building and then we digest
those insights and we also produce
another endpoint which is really about
the insights of the building and solar
potential for a specific building that
you you might be querying and this I'll
tell you a little bit more about why
that's important but this is key solar
information really at this like I need
to need a quick hit what is the solar
potential of this building
so the API is based on what we learned
from the project sunroof tool that we
launched in 2015 is a consumer face tool
that has helped countless homeowners
around the world understand whether
solar is right for them and we're
working with industry Partners over the
last few years to understand what they
needed to really accelerate their
businesses Drive customer trust and
ultimately deploy more solar so with our
expanded coverage with the data and
imagery that you need to create
accurative accurate and competitive
solar proposals we hope this increases
your conversions reduces your number of
site visits and decreases your site
design times for solar installations
the API was designed to support use
cases across the entire solar
installation funnel from customer
awareness to acquisition to panel layout
to design and installation guides you
can use the API to support specific
buildings but a specific building in
front of a customer and say this is your
roof this is you know these are the
panels on your roof you know solar is
right for you you can take that down a
level and put a distinct quote together
that says this is you need seven panels
on your roof to and they're going to be
on this corner of the roof you can
create designs there and then you can
create installation guides as well so
you can use the raw solar data to really
say okay here's my installers you need
to go to this part of the roof it's this
tall then you bring that ladder with
them so it's everything from I have a
portfolio of buildings which one's right
for solar we can do that and it's down
to the level of I need to put panels
where that's what we're really excited
about with with this tool
so the solar API we're excited to launch
it to 40 countries covering 320 million
buildings this coverage supports
businesses and customers at scale helps
you provide it gives you the ability to
expand your business into new markets
we're not done though we know new
buildings are coming up all the time we
know that they're interested in
distributed solar on residential
commercial roofs is not limited to these
countries and we're super excited to
hear more about what is needed in the
world how do we how do we help
accelerate solar installers even more so
if you have ideas I'm here to listen to
those
but to tell you a little bit more about
solar and how it's being used by one of
our customers I want to introduce us
thank you thank you Celine thank you for
having me here
um
my name is and I will tell a story about
closing Gap but that's what we've been
doing the last couple of years
but we're on a mission to help the
European Union to achieve Montero peak
of installed capacity in 2030. that's
our mission that's what we're working on
and we're doing since 2009.
to explain that I have two short stories
one about how we grew our company over
the last couple of years and the other
about the complexity of the energy
market and what it means
we started in 2009 a couple of my
colleagues they looked at certain
problems in the spatial planning area
and they also saw a question about solar
and they looked at what kind of data was
available full available and how they
could use that and they saw there was
laser scanning data lidar data which is
translated now into a DSM model and they
saw building boundary data and he
started thinking about it and he had the
intuition they could build something of
it and it started with a first algorithm
and for one building it took over a week
to calculate it well the end result was
great but a week then already was too
much so they started improving improving
and in 2010 we got to the point that we
could calculate a complete City within a
week and share the results of that in a
solar map to a municipality or city so
that the the inhabitants could see what
the potential of the roof was that was
the first start the main issue was that
we needed to have data the data was not
available it was always only available
through a governmental agency took a lot
of time a lot of effort so we started
looking for other source of data and in
2014 there was a big moment the European
Union had a legislation that
made sure that every country would be
able should be able to provide the open
data there were two countries who did
that the Netherlands and Denmark
and we had some great results with that
and then we started waiting waiting
waiting for the other countries to
follow didn't happen and then Google
sunroof project was the next thing first
step for us because we saw that that's
another alternative we already had
reference data sets which we could use
to validate the date of Google and we
saw that it was good for what we wanted
to do so we started with projects in
Germany and the UK doing the same thing
again
then again before a lot more data became
available it took a lot of time so some
of the countries in the EU gave data
available but still not enough and then
in 2022 the discussion with Google
started again and they decided the
Google son of project will become a
commercial product which was a great
decision for Google but also for us in
the end and that led to us launching the
Montero Peak initiative this year at
intersol air Munich big solar Invention
Convention
the other story is about the solar
market and but
um
I already had solar panels on my roof in
1996. I don't know who if you have solar
panels on the roof can you raise your
hand
so still still a lot of people to
convert to using solar that's great
um
um when I bought my house in 1996 it had
already solar panels only because it was
part of the deal so it was not that
difficult to buy them what you see here
is the blue line is the complexity of
the market in it and during the last
couple of years the complexity increased
a lot so new products without batteries
whether the heat pumps with it um if you
look at for instance the energy
contracts that you can get so the
complexity is but it's growing a lot and
the other thing
people trusted the energy Market it was
easy to understand and that trust
declined very fast to the point where
there is now a gap between the
complexity of the market and the trust
that people have in that market and
that's what we're closing we're closing
that Gap
that's for trying to establish
and I have to click through this yes
um
another part is what we saw that if the
blue line is what kind of data is
necessary to give good advice to
consumers or to businesses
um the initiative in the Nellis and
Denmark made it possible to advise those
countries really well and what's
possible in the other countries it was
really difficult over small data sets a
lot of work to to do the data quality
checks with the availability of the
Google solar API that becomes a lot more
easy for us to do so we can close the
gap now at this moment but only at this
moment Saleem already said new buildings
will come new Solutions will be there so
it is a challenge to keep ahead of the
trust versus complexity of the challenge
that we're facing
that's the two stories that converge
what we have done over the years is we
have created solutions for governments
to educate on the potential of solar but
also for commercial companies to help
raise the conversion of their sales
processes those are the really important
things that we've done and we're doing
that with now with the new Google solar
API far better faster than ever before
this is what we have achieved so far in
Europe and we're really proud of that
that we have achieved that that's really
something that every time we look at
this figures we say wow but it's still
not enough if you look in the room how
many people already have solar panels
it's not enough you have to be more
send them what do we have from technical
perspective
we we know of each roof part the Tilt
the orientation we know the size and we
use that to estimate scenarios what is
the best option for your energy
consumption or your future energy
consumptions
um we know what objects are in the
neighborhood and we can use that to
calculate how much Shadow there will be
and how much actually the radiation will
hit the roof parts
we know we can create online real-time
the first indication of a solar plant is
used in whether it's an educational
purposes and also in commercial
situations to help to give the the fuel
and understanding what is possible
we know the height and the height of the
lowest roof part and also of the highest
rule part the lowest Row part is really
important to understand
what's the height of the safety meshes
that you need to take into account
safety measures are really necessary but
also very costly so explaining that to
an installer is really important
we know about the the situation around
the building which is important if you
look at from the perspective of the
individual who wants to buy a solar
plant explaining this is your house this
is what the Shader will do and this is
what the potential installation can be
helps them into making the decision to
buy a solar plant
and again these two stories now convert
what we're trying to do every day every
week is make sure that we close the gap
between complexity and trust and make
sure that that our customers with our
municipalities which are the commercial
companies which are individuals use that
data to start using Renewables and
that's for me thank you for now
thank you boss
so from here we're going to switch to
the other apis we're launching today to
tell you more I'd like to introduce Ron
korber an environmental engineer who's
also the director of product
thank you Celia according to the world
of organization air pollution is among
the greatest environmental health risk
which we face today
which accounts for more than 7 million
premature death every year
also due to climate change there is an
increase in going phenomenon of other
environmental hazards such as wildfires
and pollen
this all creates a huge Healthcare cost
and according to the World Bank the cost
of air pollution alone is more than 8
trillion dollar annually
in current times when health and climate
change is top of mind for individuals
businesses and authorities every
consumer experience every product and
every business process must become
climate over and climate resilient
which is why we are very excited to
introduce the neural quality API and the
new ipolling API as part of the new
environmental category on Google Maps
platform alongside with solar API this
is all part of Google commitment making
reliable relevant environmental data
available to the masses
with the newer quality API in the new
pollen API we don't only provide
accurate data but also heat map
capabilities as well as recommendations
on how to reduce exposure and yes this
can all be available with easily to
integrate apis which can be used on
every new or current business
applications or websites let me tell you
more about what is available via the
apis
air quality is a new capability that
provides current and historical data the
air quality apis provide granular air
quality data to help innovate your
product and style your map in order to
visualize air pollution exposure
this enables people to understand the
air they are within and make an informed
decision such as choosing the right park
the cleanest Park to take the children
outside limiting out of stay or choose
where and when to do other activity
key features include real-time air
quality index which is hourly air
quality information available in over
100 countries at an astonishing
resolution of 500 meter or 1600 feet
resolution
also available is a very intuitive air
pollution map which is color-coded
representation of the air that we breed
we also provide other features such as
health tips and recommendation which are
hundreds of recommendations on how to
avoid exposure based on seven population
segments for example recommendation for
asthma patients COPD patients athletes
and more
moving on to Poland
polon is a natural phenomenon which also
have a significant health
cost on society with over
400 million seasonal allergy suffers
globally
in a world where Paul encounts are
rising and Poland season are getting
longer and at the same time aren't
predictable there is an increase in
demand for accurate pollen forecast
therefore the Poland API is a new
capability based on very Advanced models
that calculate the pollen index for
three Poland types and for up to 15
pollen plant species
this is available on a one by one
kilometer Square Grid in 65 countries
and yes just like the air quality API
Poland iopi also include heat map
capabilities which you can display on
top of your Google Maps
a variety of Industry
the pollen and air quality apis and
those Industries include Smart Home
Healthcare Mobility travel government
media and big Tech real estate insurance
and more and I will be happy to give you
a couple of examples
in the healthcare market for example the
Mongol customers are medical companies
and pharmaceutical companies
for seasonal allergy suffers
there are good news because there are
treatment that can be efficient in order
to prevent or avoid related symptoms
however this are mostly efficient
if taken before allergic symptoms start
so among the use cases there are apps
that provide alerts for seasonal allergy
suffers so for example if we see that
pollen count might be high it's a user
location according to a forecast these
apps will run this user this patient in
order for him to make informed decision
on how to reduce exposure for example
closing the windows at his home or even
use his personal preventative medicine
it is also no surprise that exposure to
air pollution during our daily commute
might have a negative impact on our
health
so therefore in the mobility and
automotive industry air quality
important data allow for more informed
driving decisions
passenger and drivers can use the data
to find alternative route to reduce
exposure they can also make other
informed decisions such as turn on the
in-cabin air purifier in Del column
the air quality in Poland API can be
easily integrated into the car HMI as
well as a driver companion app so the
driver can make sure the car is prepared
and optimized before the Journey Begins
next Emil Fisher director of research
and Engineering at Google will elaborate
more on the unique Dynamic of air
pollution and how we are able to provide
accurate environmental data Emil thanks
okay thanks Juan so
hi everybody
okay so people sometimes wrongly assume
that they are exposed to pollution only
when they are located to uh really next
to a pollution Source such as if they
are next to a busy traffic jam or you
know or a wildfire but actually the
reality is a bit different people it can
be also exposed to flower pollution
sources such as dust storms that can
travel great distance and can cause
oceans and even continents
Okay so
you can see here time lapse video
presentation of the air quality changes
in the Bay Area
you can see how where
how their quality changes you know from
one street to another and and and of
course you can see the colors the colors
represents a green represents gooder
quality which is healthy for everybody
yellow represents a moderated air
quality which can be harmful for
sensitive groups just like you know
asthma patients and red represents
better quality which is harmful for
everybody even for short exposure of
times less than one hour
as you can see the air quality changes
dramatically from one street to another
from a from one hour hour to another and
and from good to bed
so as you can see
this is very this is also very
challenging to map the pollution at your
exact location
and and
and and there are several reasons for
that one is delays in reporting and also
a coverage between sensors
cool so to resolve this to resolve this
challenge we are using sophisticated
algorithms and and what we're doing we
are fusing multiple data layers we are
taking we are taking traffic information
we are taking weather conditions
different models we are using a fire
smoke models Etc to calculate the
pollution in more than 100 countries in
a resolution as well mentioned of around
500 meters which is around 1600 feet
this unique approach enables us to
provide information even when one of the
data sources is unavailable we calculate
the pollution in around 500 million
geographical locations around the world
in those locations we calculate the
pollution of the pollutant
concentrations of billions of different
pollutant concentration types SPM 2.5 PM
tens and and others and overall we
digest terabytes of data and we also
support more than 70 different air
quality indexes basically those are
official governmental Global air quality
indexes that we can provide anywhere
also a similar approach we are taking
with the Poland modeling or Poland
forecasting we use Infuse multiple data
layers such as land cover and total
production per pollen type and climate
data and then we are able to provide
meaningful information such as pollen
index which is a universal and Global
pollen index we can also provide
exposure exposure risks actionable
insights and heat Maps
so you're asking yourself why now so
according to the World Health
Organization air pollution is one of the
biggest environmental health risks this
is why the who took a bold action and in
the first time in 16 years they reduced
their air pollution thresholds and
updated their guidelines
this creates a lot of sense of urgency
among governments companies and people
and also the news coverage about air
pollution pollen and wildfires change
drastically and there are now as you see
everywhere also we see that many world
leaders and the CEOs of large companies
they'll focused themselves on on
realizing sustainability
so I'm really excited
to announce the general availability of
our new air quality and pollen apis as
part of our new also environmental
product Suite available via Google maps
platform if your company is looking to
bring real value to your users to
increase brand loyalty and trust and
increase engagement and help your
communities so their quality and polling
apis were created exactly for that to
support multiple business segments
across many health related use cases
that again to bring real value to your
users thank you